(audience applause)
- So our daughters are about the same age.
So is it true that she's like,
completely taken over
your Spotify playlist?
- [Jenna] For sure, I..
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
- [Jenna] Aww, Evie.
- [Kelly] Beautiful little thing.
- She's so cute.
Yes, my Spotify has been taken over,
however,
Evie's into Irish dance.
So this is her biggest, hugest passion.
- [Kelly] This is interesting.
Where did this influence come from?
- We watched river dance.
- Oh!
- [Jenna] I swear to you.
I showed her river dance
videos and she was like,
she looked at me and
all honestly was like,
"I want to do this.
Find me a dance class."
And we had done,
- [Kelly] Oh,
- Ballet, tap wasn't looking good.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Jenna] It was not.
She went into,
- [Kelly] Yeah,
- [Jenna] I Googled, found a woman here,
and she started classes and she became,
- (in unison) Obsessed.
- And we are dance competitions.
We do the whole thing, but she..
- Are you the dance mom?
Smile baby.
Like are you?
- No.
(Kelly and audience laugh)
- You know what's funny is I grew up,
I grew up as a dancer, obviously.
- Yeah obviously yeah
- And dance competitions.
But my mom was not a dance mom,
so she was really grounded.
So I am at these competitions but,
there are moments where,
I mean and Evie's really good.
She does great.
Like she's amazing.
But there's moments where I'm like,
"I wanna tell her to point a foot",
but I can't, because then,
you know, you're the mom
telling her what to do.
So I go, "oh, wanna get around to it."
And she's like, "I don't wanna hear it.
I don't wanna have it."
And the back of my mind I'm going,
"I do this for a living."
Like,
- [Kelly] Yeah,
- there are some critiques
that I can give you.
- Yeah. I'm actually a good
resource at this moment.
- I'm good resource,
Like I can tell you if you,
- [Kelly] She doesn't care.
- Nope. No.
- My daughter performed
singing in a school thing and,
yeah she didn't want any input.
And I was like, "sure, don't ask me."
- But I get it.
- Yeah
(audience laugh)
- Yeah yeah,
- (laughing) Don't ask me.
- I was fine about it,
but I was just like, "all right."
But you know what, we're raising
like confident, bold tone
And I love that.
- I was actually, I, I'm great with it.
I think it's a adorable,
and I want her to have her own experience.
I don't wanna give it,
but it is really funny.
And so here I am back
at dance competitions,
but that's why my Spotify,
she only listens to Celtic music.
- A bunch of Irish Celtic music
- (laughingly) Yes.
So my Spotify is like,
the Celtic woman who
by the way is amazing.
I love them.
But it's also,
Irish Jake music and
and the heavy jig and the smooth jig,
- That kind of is happy music.
- It's super happy.
- Yeah.
- But you know, 15,
- Kind of a lot,
- 20 minutes in.
- Yeah.
- "Could we, top 40?
Like anything?"
Like "Nope."
- Any, any other general do?
- [Jenna] We are Celtic Woman.
Celtic Christmas.
We've got, it is,
- [Kelly] I love that.